in the lobby of Ramsey solutions at
Dennis and Kelly are with us hey guys
how are you good how are ya Dave good
better than I deserve
welcome welcome where're you guys from
Kincaid Illinois we're uh 30 miles south
of Springfield all right very good fun
welcome to Nashville so you're here to
do your debt-free scream we are how much
of you paid off forty four thousand in
eight months good job very good and
making what range of income during that
time well we're about ninety and then uh
now up to 130 good for you very cool
what you guys do for a living I'm a
third grade school teacher all right
I'm a theater driver at UPS perfect very
good and the three young men with you
what are their names and ages Michael 7
Carter 7 Anthony 12 ah twins huh yep all
right very cool very cool
Sharon's a twin so that's fun times a
lot of fun good stuff
all right so $44,000 what kind of debt
was that that was the rest of our
mortgage Oh your house yeah yeah I'm
looking at weird people that is serious
fun right well congratulations you guys
very very very well done so tell me the
story
what happened eight months ago it
probably actually started prob about 405
mm-hmm
we paid out we started paying off our
consumer debt then listening to you and
then all along before the twins were
born Kelly wanted to stay home which was
the best decision of our lives sure I I
wasn't forward at first but then after
it happened it was great so she stayed
home for seven or eight years we were
plugging along paying off the house and
then she went that position opened up
back in the fall last year and eight
months later we decided to pay off the
house boom there you go
so what point were you connected with us
in this journey back in 405 okay so you
in what way funny together we were
paying we were making about 90 grand a
year together we're both working working
and we bought this I thought she needed
a new SUV no for Toyota Sequoia nice SUV
oh we got real Mars yeah well she she
lives we live right across the street
from the school mm-hmm really didn't
need the SUV yeah I gotta tell you we
still drive it today though okay so
we're still got it we're still plugging
along in it but it started it started
then and I know we made about 90 grand
that year we're sitting at the table
doing our taxes Kelly I said this is
crazy
we make a ton of money and we have all
this debt and well then I she said what
do you want for your birthday my
birthday is March I said I want to be
out of debt I'm done I'm tired of it so
she bought me your book and it's all her
fault
oh there it goes just like that she was
kicking and screaming the whole way so
Total Money Makeover yeah good for you
guys
and then we got it really and then back
eight months ago we when she went back
to work
we got plugged into every dollar and
that really helped oh yeah because I'm
kind of controlling sometimes when she
goes shopping in that well I've been
known to be controlling me too now that
it's in the budget I feel a lot better
about everything that she spends because
I know she knows what she can spend no
challenge we still have money in the
grocery fund you know I didn't go in
there it's you know rachel says it's
permission to spend right and it it does
get rid of the controlling because it
won't you know once I say this amount
I'm good I'm not controlling anymore
that I'm just saying that amount right
it makes me feel a lot better right that
works good I got rid of a lot of fights
between us definitely
I never thought of every dollar saving
marriages but I guess it will very cool
we're gonna give you guys a copy of
Chris Hogan's new book the number one
bestseller retire inspired us signed by
him because this is the next step now on
the air er you've gotten the house paid
off in everything Wow what's this house
worth 150 maybe 160 very cool
yeah very good it's great and you own it
we own it your house is paid for yep
yeah you're weird
well done well done
how's it feel to not have a payment in
the world
it feels good that's awesome it is yeah
can't can't describe it I'll never go
back there is something there's a
something that comes off of you that you
didn't even know is on you it is it's
like a film or something that comes off
of you like you were in the side this
force field or something is removed it's
very weird every week that paycheck goes
in the bank it's and you see the the
amounts climbing that's great now once
you get out very few people ever want to
go back no we're not I just say that's
it I'm done I'm done
oh well done all right Dennis and Kelly
Anthony Michael and Carter $44,000
that's their house and everything man
paid off in eight months making 90 to
130 count it down guys let's hear a debt
free scream ready three two one
that's how it works that's how it works
I love it I love it I love it
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show you can do this you know that
really is a message whether you've got
two hundred seventy thousand dollars in
student loan debt or 27 thousand well
you've got a fifty thousand dollar
income on a five hundred thousand dollar
economy
[Music]